Professor Ben Polak:
Last time we looked at how
to apply our new idea of
sub-game perfect equilibrium to
a whole bunch of games,
and our general idea for how to
solve the sub-game perfect
equilibrium is as follows.
We looked at each sub-game.
We solved for the Nash
equilibrium in the sub-game,
that is something we learned to
do long ago.
And then we rolled back the
payoffs: we rolled them back up
the tree.
And towards the end we learned
something interesting.
I'm not going to go back to it
today--I just want to emphasize
it.
We learned that strategic
effects matter.
So in that investment game we
looked at last time,
when you're considering whether
to rent a new piece of
machinery,
it made a very big difference
whether you considered how this
action would affect the actions
of the other side;
in this case,
how it affects your
competition.
This is a very general idea,
a very general point.
So just to give you a couple of
more examples,
when you're designing tax
systems--I mentioned this last
time--when you're designing a
tax system,
to make some changes in the
U.S.
tax system, it's not good
enough to look at how people are
behaving in the old tax system
and just calculate in an
accounting manner how much more
money you're going to raise,
or how much money it's going to
cost you.
You have to take into account
how that's going to lead to
changes in behavior.
Once again, that's a strategic
effect, and in the homework that
you're handing in today,
all of you will have had a nice
example of that in the toll
booth problem.
So in the toll booth problem,
when you're putting tolls on
roads--or more generally,
when you're building new roads,
new bridges,
new flyovers,
new bypasses,
you need to take into account
how those new tolls,
how those new roads will affect
all of traffic flow.
Traffic flow down the tree will
form a new equilibrium and you
need to consider that in
designing your tolls and
designing your road system.
So that's another example of
SPE.
So today I want to do something
quite different,
a little bit like what we did
with duel,
I want to play a game today,
and probably spend the whole of
today analyzing this one game.
So it's quite a complicated
game, but it's quite a fun game.
So what's the game we're going
to look at?
The game is going to involve
two players, and each player in
each period, they choose--or
each chooses I should say--each
chooses,
whether to fight or to quit.
So F means fight and Q means
quit, and they make this choice
simultaneously.
The game ends as soon as
someone quits.
So there's good news and bad
news for this game.
Let's do the good news first.
The good news is that if the
other player quits first you win
a prize.
Generally we'll call this prize
V, but we'll play for some cash
in a minute.
The bad news is,
each period in which both
fight--so each period in which
both players choose to
fight--each player pays a cost,
so they pay -C.
Just to keep things interesting
let's fill in the other thing
here which is if both quit at
once--so if both quit at once
then they get 0 that period.
So this is a game we've seen a
little bit before.
We saw a little bit under the
auspices of Hawk Dove.
Those people in the MBA class
saw a game a lot like this.
But we're going to analyze this
in much more detail then we did
before.
As I said, we're going to spend
the whole of today talking about
it.
So, to start this out,
let's actually play this game.
So I want two volunteers.
Let me just,
since this is college football
season, let me see if I can play
off the rivalries.
So do I have anybody here from
the great state of Texas?
A whole bunch of Texans,
keep your hands up.
I want to use you a second and
I guess the rivalry here is
Oklahoma.: Anybody from
Oklahoma?
No Oklahomans?
What we'll do is we'll pick two
Texans then.
We'll assume this is Texas and
Texas A&M.
So Texans raise their hands
again.
All right, we're going to pick
out two Texans and I'm going to
give you a mike each.
So your name is?
Student: Nick.
Professor Ben Polak:
Why don't you keep hold of
the mike and just point it
towards you when you speak,
but still shout because
everyone here wants to hear you.
So this is Nick,
where was my other Texan back
here?
Why don't I go for the closer
one.
We'll start here.
And your name is?
Student: Alec.
Professor Ben Polak:
Alec, so shout it out.
Student: Alec.
Professor Ben Polak:
That's better,
okay.
So the game is this.
They're going to have to write
down for the first period
whether they choose fight or
quit.
Each player will have a referee.
So the person behind Alec is
going to be Alec's referee to
make sure that Alec is actually
saying what he says he's going
to do.
And what happened to my other
Texan.
I've lost my other Texan.
There he is.
Your name again was?
Student: Nick.
Professor Ben Polak:
Nick is going to write down
fight or quit.
And to make this real,
let's play for some real cash.
So we'll make the prize--why
don't we make the prize equal to
a $1 and the cost equal to $.75.
So I've got some dollars here.
Here we go.
What do we call this?
In Texas we call this a fist
full of dollars,
is that right?
So where are my players?
Why don't you stand up,
you guys.
So everyone can see you.
I made this difficult,
because now you are going to
have to write down your
strategy.
So you are going to have to
grab a pen.
I didn't make that easy for you.
Let me come down to make it
easier for the camera person.
So why don't you write down
what your strategy is going to
be, and tell your neighbor what
it's going to be,
and we'll see what happened.
Show your referee.
Have you shown your referee?
Nick, speaking into the
microphone what did you do?
Student: I quit.
Professor Ben Polak:
He quit.
Student: I quit as well.
Professor Ben Polak:
What happened to remember
the Alamo?
All right, so Texas didn't work
very well.
Let's try a different state.
I have to say my wife's from
Texas and my wife's family is
from Texas, and I thought they
had more fight in them than
that.
Maybe that's why they are
sliding in the polls.
Let's try somebody from Ohio,
anyone from Ohio?
Nobody from Ohio in the whole
class, that's no good.
I was going to pick Ohio
against Michigan.
How about some people from some
of our own teams?
Are there any players on the
football team other than the two
I've picked on before?
There we go.
I need a different team,
anybody from the hockey team?
Anybody from the baseball team?
Okay good.
So our friend from the baseball
team, your name is?
Student: Chris.
Professor Ben Polak:
Chris and our new football
team player is?
Student: Ryland.
Professor Ben Polak:
Ryland.
Okay so Ryland and Chris are
going to play this.
And neither of you is from
Texas, I take it,
so we have some hope of
something happening here.
So write down what it is you're
going to choose.
Have you both written something
down?
Yeah, all right Ryland what did
you choose?
Student: Fight.
Professor Ben Polak:
Chris?
Student: I'm going to
quit.
Professor Ben Polak:
Well that was easy too.
So the football team is looking
pretty good here.
So we're not getting much in
the way of action going here.
Anyone else want to try here?
Another little state rivalry
here, I don't suppose I've got
anyone from Oregon,
that's asking too much,
anyone from Oregon?
You guys must be from somewhere.
There's got to be a state where
at least one of you is from.
Well let's try something like
New Jersey, how about that?
There's some players from New
Jersey that's good.
Here we go.
And we'll try New Jersey and
New York.
That seems like there's a bit
of a rivalry there.
Are you from New York?
Excellent, here we go,
and your name is?
Student: Geersen.
Professor Ben Polak:
Your name is?
Student: Andy.
Professor Ben Polak:
Andy.
Okay so Geersen and Andy.
So stand up so everyone can see
where you are.
Let's see if there's any fight
in New York and New Jersey.
So write down your strategies.
Andy what did you choose?
Student: I'm going to
fight.
Student: Fight.
Professor Ben Polak:
Here we go,
this is better now.
I was getting worried there for
a second.
I know it's near the
Thanksgiving break,
but there has to be some sort
of spark left in the class.
So we have both people fighting
which means right now they're
down $.75 but the prize is $1.
So the game goes on,
so write down again.
What you're going to do second
period.
The $.75 is gone so now we're
just looking at this game for
$1.
Let's go to New York,
what does New York?
Student: I'm going to
fight.
Student: Fight.
Professor Ben Polak:
Fight okay.
So you have to stay on the east
coast to get life.
There's no point going west is
there.
That makes sense.
So write down again what you're
going to do, and let's go the
other way around,
to New Jersey?
Student: Fight.
Professor Ben Polak:
Fight again all right,
so right now we're down three
$.75 whatever that is,
and there's still this prize of
$1, plus perhaps a bit of pride
here.
So write down again.
Let's try again,
so let's go with New York this
time.
Student: I'm going to
fight.
Student: Fight.
Professor Ben Polak:
Fight okay,
I'm guessing we could keep this
going for quite a while,
is that right?
Now it might make a difference,
by the way, if they're allowed
to talk to each other here,
so let's see if it does.
So let's allow New Jersey and
New York to talk to each other.
You can't insult each other
about bridges and tunnels,
just regular talk.
So anything you want to say to
your friend from New Jersey
here?
Student: I can't let New
Jersey win, that's just New York
pride.
You guys are just worse in
every realm so I'm sorry.
It's just pride.
Professor Ben Polak:
Anything you want to say in
reply?
Student: Well I'm going
to keep fighting,
so your best choice is to give
up.
Professor Ben Polak:
Let's see if that works.
Did they get anything out of
that?
So choose the strategies again.
New York?
Student: I just can't
let Jersey win:
fight.
Student: Bring it on:
Professor Ben Polak:
All right,
so it's clear that if we kept
this going for a while,
it would pay for my lunch,
is that right?
We'll hold it here for a second.
We'll talk about it a bit,
but thank you.
A round of applause for our two
feistier players.
So what's going on here?
So clearly we can see what can
happen in this game.
You can get people quitting
early, and it could be that one
side quits and the other side
doesn't quit.
That is also something that can
happen.
That can happen pretty quickly.
But it's possible--we just saw
it happen--it's possible that a
fight could go on quite a while
here.
Now why?
What's going on here?
I mean the prize here was what?
Was $1, and the cost was $.75.
I could have raised the stakes
maybe on these guys and see if
that made a difference,
but I think $1 and $.75 will
do.
And by the time they had fought
the second time,
they'd exhausted the possible
prize of $1.
So it's true that if you won
this in the first period then
that's fine because you just get
a $1 and it wouldn't cost you
anything.
And even if you won in the
second period you'd be okay,
you'd only cost yourself $.75
for fighting in the first
period,
but you're getting $1 so that's
good.
But there on--and "there on"
went on for plenty of time in
this case--there on you're just
accumulating losses,
so what's going on?
There are various conclusions
possible here.
One is that people from New
York and New Jersey are crazy.
That's a possible thing.
But what else is going on.
Why did we get involved in this
fight.
What happened here?
Why do we tend to see fights
like this emerging?
I'm claiming this isn't such an
implausible situation.
Why do we see it emerging?
Let's talk to our friend from
New York, shout out.
Student: By the time she
fought with me on the second
round, I knew I was going to be
losing money anyway so why not
just keep going and then,
there was no reason,
I wasn't going to win anyway,
so I might as well just keep
fighting until she quit.
Professor Ben Polak:
All right,
I think there's two things.
There's two parts to that
answer.
Part of the answer is:
I have lost the money anyway,
let's hold that piece of it.
And the other part of it is
what?
The other part of it is I'm
really determined to win this
thing.
So there's two things going on
there, and they're quite
different.
Let's take the second one first.
It's possible that the reason
these fights emerge and can go
on for quite a while is that
even though the prize is only $1
in money,
it could be that the actual
thing that the players care
about is what?
What do the players actually
care about here?
Somebody just raise your hand,
I'll put you on the mike.
What do people tend to care
about in these situations?
Winning, they care about
winning, or they care about
pride.
Is that right?
That's why I started with
Texas, but I couldn't find any
pride in Texas,
so we had to go to New York.
So people care about winning
per se.
It's a pride thing.
So it could be that $1 simply
isn't a good description of the
true payoffs here.
It could be that the payoffs
are actually about winning.
It could also be that both of
these guys know that they're
going to be interacting with you
at other times in the class,
or other times at Yale.
And they want to establish a
reputation, both of them,
as being the kind of guys who
fight.
In particular,
when they got to talk about it,
both of them said:
"look I'm a fighter":
something which we've seen
before with Ale and his pizza
shop.
Both of them said:
"I'm a fighter.
You better back out."
So both of them tried to signal
the fact that they were going to
fight to try and get the other
side to quit.
So that's about reputation,
and that reputation could
extend beyond this game.
It could be that they're going
to be involved in this kind of
conflict later on in life.
So both of those things are
around.
There's another element to
this, and it's the other part of
what our friend from New York
said which is about the costs.
What's true about the costs in
this game as we move from period
to period?
Somebody said it.
Say it again.
Say it loudly.
Student: Sunk cost.
Professor Ben Polak:
It's a sunk cost.
So all of those costs that you
accumulate as the game goes on,
they're irrelevant looking
forward because they're sunk.
The fact I've played this game
for ten periods and hence lost
ten times $.75--which even I can
do,
that's $7.50--the fact that
I've lost $7.50 is irrelevant
because I've lost it anyway.
I can't get that back.
That's a sunk cost.
So the game ten periods through
looks exactly the same as the
game did at the beginning,
when fighting seemed a good
option.
So ten periods through the
game, you have the same view
about fighting as you did at the
beginning.
Now that's not quite true
because at some point you're
going to run out of money,
but if we ignore that,
basically, those sunk costs are
irrelevant.
So what we're seeing here is
reasons why people fight and
some of these reasons seem to be
for standard economic reasons
like sunk costs,
and some of them seem to be
about things that are outside
the game like pride or possibly
reputation.
It's certainly the case within
the real world,
we do see fights like this.
Let's just spell out what the
key feature of this is.
The key feature of this is,
in these fights over a period
of time, even though you may
only be losing a little piece in
each period,
over a period of time you could
lose a lot.
In fact, you could lose far
more than the prize that was
originally at stake.
So the losses you could
accumulate--and our friend from
New Jersey and New York,
the losses that they
accumulated vastly outweighed
the prize that was at stake
after a while.
That's a worry.
So this can occur in real life
not just in the classroom.
What do we call these kinds of
fights;
these fights where they're
holding out for this possibly
small prize and incurring,
possibly small--but they
accumulated to being
large--costs each period.
What do we call those fights?
Let's think about some examples.
Let's see if the word comes out
of examples.
So one example--let's do some
examples here.
One example is what happened in
World War I.
So in World War I,
as I'm assuming most of you
know, on the western front at
least,
the German and allies to
Germany armies faced off with
the British and French and
allied armies,
for an extraordinarily long
time, fighting over
extraordinarily small patches of
land,
little pieces of northern
France and Belgium.
You could argue that these
pieces of northern France and
Belgium--I don't wish to offend
anyone French or Belgian
here--but you could argue that
those few acres of northern
France and Germany weren't worth
a whole lot anyway.
Nevertheless,
the two sides kept on fighting
from 1914 to 1918,
and enormous losses of life
were accumulated in that period.
So that was a really costly,
long term battle.
Neither side would quit.
Each year huge numbers of lives
were lost.
If you doubt that go and look
at the war memorial in Yale that
shows how many Yale American
lives were lost,
and America was only in that
war for about a year.
Okay, so that's an example.
Another example--a more
business example,
an example we talked about in
our MBA class but not in this
class so far--is examples in
business where there's a market
and that market is really only
going to hold one firm.
That market is only going to
hold one firm.
You can end up in an extremely
long fight about who's going to
end up being the one firm in
that market.
So a famous example--actually
it's a famous business school
case--is the fight that ocurred
to control satellite
broadcasting in Europe.
So there was a fight between
Sky Television and the British
Satellite Broadcasting Company
that went on for a number of
years.
And these companies were doing
things like charging zero
prices, and giving away
satellite dishes,
and this that and the other.
And over the course of the
fight they accumulated so many
losses that, if you did the
accounting,
the entire future projected
profit flow of winning this
fight was vastly outweighed by
the amount of money that they'd
lost during the fight.
That was a fight that involved
on one side Rupert Murdock and
you can argue maybe Rupert
Murdock is a little crazy and
had a reputation to keep up,
but still it looks like another
example of this.
So that example was British
Satellite Broadcasting versus
Sky.
So with those two examples
there, anyone think of a general
term we call these fights?
How do people refer to the
method of fighting in World War
I--or for that matter during the
American Civil War?
Somebody in the back,
shout it out.
Student: War of
attrition.
Professor Ben Polak:
It's a war of attrition.
So these are wars of attrition.
These are wars of attrition.
And what we know about wars of
attrition is that they can go on
a long time, and a lot can be
lost.
A lot of life can be lost in
the case of real wars.
A lot of money can be lost in
the case of business wars.
Actually it turns out,
a lot of games have this
structure of a war of attrition.
Let me give you one more
example.
Suppose that two companies are
competing for a market not in
the manner of BSB and Sky by the
advertising or whatever,
but in the form of paying
bribes.
So suppose there's a company
let's say in France and a
company let's say in Britain,
and these two companies are
trying to win a contract in some
country where paying bribes is a
successful strategy.
And here I'm going to be
careful about the film and not
mention any real companies,
so let's call this imaginary
country Freedonia,
which comes from a Marx
Brothers film.
So here's this French company
and this British company,
and they both want this
contract to build a bridge in
Freedonia.
And they start paying bribes to
the general who controls
Freedonia.
And what happens?
Well you're not going to get
the bribe back.
So both sides pay a few
thousand dollars to this
general, and then the general
comes back and says,
well you both paid $1,000.
Which of you wants to pay the
bridge?
So they go on,
and they put more money in and
more money in.
And you can see once again this
is a war of attrition.
Those bribes that they've paid,
they're never getting back,
but once you've paid them
they're a sunk cost.
Once you've paid that bribe,
good luck saying:
I paid you this bribe.
You didn't let me build the
bridge.
Give me my money back.
There isn't a court in the
world that's going to enforce
that.
So these bribery contests look
a lot like this.
There's a technical name for
these bribe contests,
they're sometimes called all
pay auctions.
So what do we want to establish
today?
We want to establish-- we want
to talk about why fighting
occurs here and we wanted to do
so in some detail.
So there may be informal
reasons why fighting occurs and
we've talked about that.
It could be that one side is
crazy.
It could be that both sides are
It could be that national or
regional pride is at stack.
All of these things could
affect why we get fighting.
But what I want to try and
establish today is that you can
get long fights emerging in
potential wars of attrition even
if everybody is rational,
even if the payoff is just that
one dollar, and even if there's
no reputation at stake.
So again, my goal today is to
try and convince you that you
can get huge loss of life in
World War I or huge loss of
money in these business contexts
without having to argue
something outside the model like
irrationality or reputation.
Even rational players can get
themselves in trouble in wars of
attrition.
So for the rest of today,
I want to try and analyze this.
To get us started I want to
look at a version of this game,
at a simplified version,
which only lasts for two
periods.
So we'll do a two period
version of the game we played
just now.
Eventually, by the end of
today, I want to look at the
infinite version.
So we'll start small.
We'll start with a two period
version.
The trick in analyzing these
things is to be able to come up
with a tree and to be able to
come up with payoffs,
and be able to apply the
analysis that we know about to
get us to where we want to be.
So here's the game I claim.
I claim that it has the
following tree.
So first of all Player A
chooses and Player A can either
Fight or Quit.
And let me put a [1],
and we'll see what the [1]
is in a second.
Then we're going to model
Player 2.
But of course this is a
simultaneous move game.
This is a simultaneous move,
so this is an information set.
Let's not call him Player 2.
Let's call him Player B.
So Player B doesn't know what A
has done that first period when
B is making her choice.
This is a simultaneous move.
And B is choosing between
fighting or quitting.
Just to distinguish them,
let me use small letters for B,
so once again fight or quit,
and fight or quit.
Now, if both sides fight then
the game continues.
And everyone knows that both
sides fought at that stage.
So at this point on,
we're actually at a singleton
information node and it's Player
A's turn again.
So here we go again.
So in the second period,
once again, we've got A
choosing whether to Fight or
Quit.
And this time we'll put a [2]
to indicate we're in the second
period.
And after Player 2 has moved
once again--after Player A has
moved--once again Player B is
moving.
That's a simultaneous move.
And once again they're choosing
fight or quit.
I'll put [2]
to indicate that we're in the
second stage.
So that's the structure of this
two period game.
And let's write down what the
payoffs are, starting with the
easy payoffs.
So if both people quit in the
first stage, they get nothing.
If A quits and B fights,
then A gets nothing and B gets
V.
If A fights and B quits,
then A gets V and B gets
nothing.
And if they both fight we go
into the second stage.
So let's write down the payoffs
in the second stage.
So in the second stage,
if they both quit in the second
stage then their payoffs are
going to be,
for A, -C, the costs they
accumulated in the first stage,
plus 0.
And, for B, -C + 0.
If A quits and B fights in the
second stage then the payoffs
are -C + 0 and -C + V.
If A fights and B quits then
the payoffs are -C + V and -C +
0.
And if they both fight for two
periods, we have a decision to
make about how we're going to
end the game in this two period
game,
but let's just assume that what
we'll get here is -C -C and -C
-C.
We'll assume if they both fight
the game ends and no one gets
the prize, just to make life
simple.
So this is a two period version
of the game and the only change
I've made, other than making it
two periods, is I had to put in
a payoff.
I had to see what happened if
the game didn't resolve.
And I've assumed that if the
game didn't resolve,
no one got the prize.
Now there's another assumption
I'm going to have to make before
we analyze this,
there are two possible cases to
consider here.
There's the case when V >
C which is the case we just
played in the class;
and there's also the converse
case when C >
V.
So today we'll focus on the
case V > C which is the case
we just played in class.
I'm going to leave you to
analyze the other case,
the case when the cost is
bigger than the prize,
as a homework assignment.
So V > C is our assumption.
So everyone okay with the tree?
This tree I hope describes the
game, at least a two period
version of the game.
Now the first thing I want to
point out here is,
if we look at the payoffs that
are incurred at the end of the
second period game,
we notice that they all contain
a –C.
There's a -C everywhere.
What is that -C?
It's the cost that you
accumulated from having fought
in the first stage.
But the observation I want to
make straight away is that this
cost--so here it is,
here it is, here it is,
here it is, and here it is,
and here it is--this cost is
sunk.
These objects here are sunk
costs.
There's nothing you can do once
you're in the second period of
the game to get these sunk costs
back.
They're just gone.
They're there,
but the fact that they enter
everywhere is going to make them
strategically irrelevant.
Okay, so what we want to do
here is we want to find all of
the sub-game perfect equilibria
of this little game.
Let me get rid of the rules.
We all know the rules by now.
So our goal here is to use our
solution concept,
which is sub-game perfect
equilibrium, to try and analyze
this game.
So how are we going to analyze
this game in terms of sub-game
perfect equilibria?
How are we going to start that
discussion?
We've got a lot of work to do
here, where are we going to
start in finding sub-game
perfect equilibria?
What's the first thing we
should do?
Well, I claim the first thing
we should do is just figure out
what the sub-games are.
Let's start with that.
So having just pushed it far
away I'm going to need to use
the pointer.
I claim that the obvious
sub-game to analyze first is
this sub-game.
It's the sub-game if you should
end up in period [2].
And notice that it is a
sub-game: it starts from a
singleton node;
it doesn't break up any
information set;
and it contains all of the
descendants of the node from
which it starts.
So that is genuinely a sub-game.
So we're going to start our
analysis by considering the
second sub-game.
So let's write down the matrix
that corresponds to that second
sub-game.
And I'm going to write it down
in the following way.
So I claim, in this second
sub-game, each player has two
choices, they can fight or quit.
And I'm going to write the
payoffs in a particular way.
I'm going to write the payoffs
as -C plus this thing.
So rather than keep that -C in
all the boxes,
which it's going to get boring
after a while,
I'm going to pull that -C out
and just put it in front.
Is that okay?
So we had this sunk cost box
everywhere and I'm going to pull
out this sunk cost box and put
it in front.
So here it is.
If you get into the second
period of the game you've
incurred this sunk cost.
And your payoffs in this game,
if you both fight then you
incur -C for the second time.
If A fights and B quits,
then A is going to win the
prize so they'll get V and
Player B will get nothing.
If B fights and A quits,
then conversely,
A gets nothing and Player B
gets the prize.
And if they both quit they just
get nothing.
So just notice what I did here,
I could have written out the
box with -C-C here;
-C-C here;
-C+V here;
-C+0 here;
-C+0 here, etc..
But I just pulled out that -C
because it's just distracting
everything.
So I pulled out that -C and put
it in the front.
Okay, so now we can analyze
this little game,
and let's start off by talking
about pure strategy equilibria
in this game.
So again, our goal is to find
sub-game perfect equilibria,
so the way in which we find
sub-game perfect equilibria is
what?
We start at the last sub-games,
we look for Nash equilibria in
those last sub-games,
and then eventually we're going
to roll those back.
So there's our last sub-game.
There's the matrix for it.
Let's just find the Nash
equilibria.
So if Player B is fighting then
Player A's best response is to
quit and if Player A is fighting
then Player B's best response is
to quit.
Conversely, if Player B is
quitting, Player A's best
response is to fight,
and if B is fighting--sorry:
if A is quitting then Player
B's best response is to fight.
I didn't say that right.
Let me try again.
So if A is fighting,
if the other side is fighting
you want to quit.
If the other side is quitting
you want to fight.
Is that clear?
So there are actually
two--let's be careful here--pure
strategy equilibria,
there are two pure strategy
Nash equilibria in this
sub-game.
What are they?
They are (Fight,quit) and
(Quit, fight).
So if we get into the second
sub-game and if we know we're
going to play a pure strategy in
the second sub-game,
this is what's going to happen,
that's our claim.
Now notice that it didn't
matter, the sunk cost didn't
matter there.
I could have included the sunk
cost in the payoffs,
but I would have found exactly
the same thing with or without
the sunk costs.
So, as we'd expect,
the sunk cost is irrelevant.
So we've got both the
equilibria in the sub-game.
Let's roll these back into the
first stage of the game.
The payoffs associated with
this one are V and 0,
and the payoff associated with
this one is 0 and V.
Everyone okay with that?
Okay, let's revisit the first
stage of this game.
Now, things get a little bit
more complicated,
so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to redraw the first stage
of this game.
So here it is.
A can fight or quit just as
before.
And, following this,
B can fight or quit just as
before.
So this is a picture of the
first stage of the game,
but I'm going to chop off the
second stage.
Let's put the payoffs in.
So the payoffs down here are
the same as they were before:
(0,0);
working up, (0, V);
if A fights and B quits then
its V,0.
But what about the payoff if
they both fight?
So what I want to do now is I
want to look at the payoff when
they both fight by considering
what they would get,
if they both fight,
in the second period of the
game.
So our idea is find the Nash
equilibrium in the second period
of the game and roll back these
possible payoffs.
So here the payoffs are going
to be -C plus stage [2]
Nash equilibrium payoffs for
Player A;
and -C plus the same thing,
stage [2]
Nash equilibrium payoffs for
Player B.
So just to understand what I've
written here then,
I put the same payoffs as
before but I've replaced that
enormous thing that was the
second stage of the game,
just with the payoffs that we
know that we're going to get in
the second stage of the game,
if we play Nash equilibrium in
the second stage.
So these objects have a name,
and the name is continuation
payoffs.
These objects are the
continuation payoffs.
They are the payoffs I'm going
to get tomorrow--and possibly
forward in a more complicated
case--if,
in this case,
if we both fight in the first
period.
Now what we want to do is we
want to draw up the matrix that
corresponds to this first stage
game, and we're going to have to
do so twice.
We're going to have to do so
once for the case where the
continuation payoffs are (V,
0), where the equilibrium we're
playing tomorrow is (Fight,
quit).
And we're going to have to do
again for the case where the
continuation payoffs tomorrow
are (0, V), namely the
continuation play is (Quit,
fight).
So we have to do it twice.
[So, you've got the
continuation payoffs down so
let's delete this to give
ourselves a little room.]
So the matrix is going to look
as follows: a nice big matrix,
2x2.
Player A is choosing Fight or
Quit, and Player B is choosing
fight or quit.
That much is easy.
It's what we put in here that
matters.
So let's do all the easy cases
first.
So (Quit, quit) is (0,0)'
(Quit, fight) is (0,V);
(Fight, quit) is (V, 0);
and in here it's going to
depend which of these two
games--which of these two
equilibria is being played
tomorrow.
So what we're going to do here
is we're going to do the case
for the equilibrium (Fight,
quit) in stage two.
We're going to write out the
matrix for the case where we're
going to play (Fight,
quit) tomorrow.
[-Thank you,
try and keep me consistent
today, because it is very easy
to slip up.
So once again I'm going to use
capital letters for Player A and
small letters for Player B.
]
So what happens if we both
fight?
We both incur costs of C from
fighting, and tomorrow we're
going to get the payoffs from
the equilibrium (Fight,
quit).
That's this equilibrium,
so we're going to get V and 0
tomorrow.
So let's add those in.
So this will be +V and this
will be +0.
And let's just put some chalk
around here to indicate that
these are going to be
continuation payoffs.
So this is the matrix we're
going to use to analyze the
first stage of the game in the
case where the equilibrium we're
playing tomorrow is (Fight,
quit).
And as I promised,
we have to do this twice.
So the other case,
of course, is if we're in the
other equilibrium tomorrow.
So let's just do that.
So once again we have Fight
[1], Quit [1];
fight [1], quit [1];and the
payoffs are--same as we
had--(0,V); (0,0);
(V, 0);
and then here,
this time, we're going to have
-C + 0 and -C + V.
And the reason for the change
is that we're now looking at the
continuation game,
the continuation play where
it's Player A who quits in the
second stage.
So this is for the case (Quit
[2], fight [2]) in period 2.
So let's just pause,
let's make sure everyone's got
that down, everyone okay?
So what we've done here is we
started off by analyzing what's
going to happen in period 2,
and that really wasn't very
hard, is that right?
That was a pretty simple game
to analyze, pretty easy to find
the equilibria.
Then what we did was we rolled
back the equilibrium payoffs
from period 2 and we plunked
them on top of the relevant
payoffs in period 1.
So in particular,
if you both fight and you know
you're going to play the (Fight,
quit) equilibrium tomorrow,
then you're payoffs will be -C
+ V and -C + 0.
If you both fight and you know
you're going to play the (Quit,
fight) equilibrium tomorrow
then you're payoffs will be -C +
0 and -C + V.
And just to emphasize once
again, these four boxes we
created correspond to the stage
2 Nash equilibrium payoffs,
so the continuation payoffs of
the game.
Okay, so now we're ready to
analyze each of these games.
So this isn't going to be too
hard.
Let's try and find out the Nash
equilibrium of this game.
So let's start with the left
hand one.
This is the case where Player A
is going to fight and win in
period 2.
So if Player B is going to quit
in period 1 then,
if Player A fights,
she gets V;
if she quits,
she gets 0: so she's going to
want to fight.
Everyone okay with that?
If Player B fights in period 2
[error; 1]
then, if Player A fights,
she gets -C + V and if she
quits she gets 0,
and here's where our assumption
is going to help us.
We've assumed,
what did we assume?
We assumed V is bigger than C,
just like we played in class.
So because V is bigger than C
this is going to be the best
response: again fighting is
going to be the best response.
So we know that,
in fact, Player A here has a
dominant strategy,
the dominant strategy is to
fight in period 1 in this
analysis of the game.
And since A is fighting,
not surprisingly,
we're going to find that B is
going to quit.
So B's best response is to quit.
So here is our Nash equilibrium
in this sub-game.
This game has a Nash
equilibrium, it only has one,
and the equilibrium is (Fight
[1], quit [1]).
Now let's just talk about it
intuitively for a second.
Intuitively,
if I know, if I'm playing Jake,
and I know that Jake is going
to fight tomorrow--sorry,
other way round--I know that
Jake's going to quit tomorrow
and I'm going to fight
tomorrow--I know that tomorrow
I'm going to win.
So that prize is there for me
tomorrow, so why would I want to
quit today?
I'm going to get $1 tomorrow if
I just fight in this period.
So why would I want to quit
today when, at worst case
scenario, I'm only going to lose
$.75 today.
So if I know Jake is quitting
tomorrow I'm going to stay on
and fight now.
And conversely,
if Jake knows he's quitting
tomorrow, hence,
he knows I'm going to fight
now, he may as well just quit.
So what we're learning here is
in this particular example,
if we know that tomorrow I'm
going to win the war,
I'm actually going to win it
today.
Say it again,
if we know that tomorrow I'm
going to win the war,
I'm actually going to win it
today.
The converse is true for the
case where I'm the quitter and
Jake's the fighter tomorrow.
So once again it's pretty quick
to see that from Jake's point of
view if I'm going to fight he's
going to want to fight.
If I'm going to quit,
he's going to want to fight.
So in either case he's going to
want to fight.
So I'm going to want to quit.
So the Nash equilibrium in this
game is (Quit [1],
fight [1]).
So at this stage,
we found all of the pure
strategy sub-game perfect
equilibria in the game.
Let's describe them before I
write them up.
One pure strategy Nash
equilibrium has me fighting in
period 1 and Jake quitting in
period 1;
and if we got to period
2--which in fact we won't--then
I fight again and he quits
again.
So let's write that equilibrium
up and we'll do it here.
We'll do it on the top board
actually.
So let me get it right,
when I write it up as a whole
equilibrium.
So I claim that I've now found
all of the pure strategy SPE in
this game.
One of them involves my
fighting in the first period and
fighting in the second period,
and Jake quitting in the first
period and quitting in the
second period.
The other one just flips it
around, I quit in the first
period, and if I got there I
would quit in the second period
and Jake fights in the first
period and,
if he got there,
he would also fight in the
second period.
So these are perfectly natural
equilibria to think about.
If you want to get it
intuitively, each of these
equilibria involves a fighter
and a quitter.
The fighter always fights,
the quitter always quits.
If I know that I'm playing a
quitter, I'm always going to
fight, so that's a best
response.
If I know I'm facing a fighter,
I'm going to want to quit,
so that's a best response and
those are two very simple
equilibria.
That's the good news.
What's the bad news here?
The bad news is we haven't
achieved our goal.
Our goal was to argue that
rational players might get
involved in a fight,
and notice that in each of
these two pure strategy sub-game
perfect equilibria,
in each of them,
no real fight occurs.
Is that right?
In each of them one person
fights for the first period,
but the other person just runs
away.
That isn't much of a fight.
Let me say it again.
In each of these equilibria,
one side is willing to fight,
but the other side isn't,
so no fight occurs.
In particular,
no costs are incurred in either
of these equilibria.
But I claimed at the beginning,
I wanted to explain how we
could have costs occur in
equilibrium.
Rational players are going to
incur costs.
So what am I missing here?
What should I do to try and
find a more costly equilibrium?
I claim I'm still missing some
equilibria here.
What kind of equilibria am I
missing?
I'm missing the mixed strategy
equilibria.
So far, all we've done is solve
out the pure-strategy equilibria
but we need to go back and
re-analyze the whole game
looking now for mixed strategy
equilibria.
So we're going to do the
entire--take a deep breath,
because we're going to take the
whole analysis we just did,
we're going to repeat the
entire analysis we just did,
but this time we're going to
look at mixed strategy
equilibria.
Everyone happy with what we're
doing?
So first of all,
we're going to go back to the
second sub-game.
Here's the second sub-game,
and we already found the pure
strategy equilibria,
so let me get rid of them,
and in your notes you probably
want to rewrite this matrix.
But I'm not going to rewrite it
here because we're a little bit
short of time.
This is exactly the same payoff
matrix we saw before,
but now I want to look for a
mixed strategy equilibrium in
this game.
How do I go about finding--it's
good review this--how do I go
about finding a mixed strategy
equilibrium in a game like this?
What's the trick for finding
mixed strategy equilibria?
Should we try our guys from New
Jersey and New York?
Let's try our guys from New
Jersey and New York.
Where's my New Yorker?
We'll have the true battle here
between New York and New Jersey,
how do we find a mixed strategy
equilibrium?
Student: You use the P's
and Q's and set them equal to
one another.
That's a very crude explanation.
Professor Ben Polak:
That's a crude thing okay.
So the answer was we find the
P's and Q's and "set them equal
to one another."
What is it we're actually
setting equal to what?
Let's try and get some response
on this.
Did our New Jersey guy flee?
Where's my New Jersey person?
They fled.
We could give our Texans
another chance.
Where's our Texan?
Tthere was a Texan down here
somewhere, what is it they set
equal to what?
Student: I guess the
chances that one would quit and
the other would fight.
Professor Ben Polak:
Not quite.
The remark about using P's and
Q's was right.
This is good review for the
final.
What is it I'm going to do with
those P's and Q's?
Shout it out.
Student: You use the
other player's payoffs.
Professor Ben Polak:
Use the other player's
payoffs and?
Student: Make them
indifferent between their
strategies.
Professor Ben Polak:
Good.
I'm going to choose Player B's
mix in such a way as to make
Player A indifferent between
choosing fight and quit.
So as to make it plausible that
A is actually mixing.
So again the intuition is for A
to be mixing they must be
indifferent between fight and
quit.
So I'm going to choose the mix
of B to make A indifferent.
So that's good review.
Let's do that.
So here I've usually used the
letter Q but to avoid confusion
here, let me use the letter P.
We're going to choose P to make
Player A indifferent.
So if A fights then their
payoff is what?
Let's have a look.
It's -C with probability P,
and V with probability of 1 -
P.
This should be coming back now.
This is before the mid-term,
but you guys were alive before
the mid-term so you should
remember this.
So if they fight,
they get -C P + V [1--P].
If they quit then they get 0
with probability P,
and 0 again with probability 1
- P.
So we know that if A is mixing,
B must be mixing in such a way
as to make these two numbers
equal.
So we know these two must be
equal to one another.
Since they're equal we can now
solve for P, so what's that
going to give us?
It's going to give us V [1--P]
= P .
C and that I think is P = V /
[V + C].
Is that right?
Someone just check my algebra.
If you remember the game of
Hawk Dove that we saw just
before the mid-term--it was a
game we looked at when we looked
at evolution--this is
essentially the same game more
or less as that game,
and that you'll notice it's the
same kind of mixture we've got
here.
So P = V / [V + C]
which means 1 - P = C / [V +
C].
I'm leaving it up there for a
bit hoping that one of the
T.A.'s is just going to do my
algebra for me.
I think that's right though.
So this game is symmetric so we
could do the same for B but
we'll find the same thing:
it's a symmetric game.
So the mixed strategy
equilibrium, the mixed Nash
equilibrium in this game has
both mix, both fight with
probability equal to V / [V +
C].
Now this is good news,
because at least we are getting
some fighting going on,
but we need to do something.
We need to take this Nash
equilibrium we've just found,
which is a Nash equilibrium in
the second sub-game.
It's a Nash equilibrium in the
sub-game way up here.
And we need to roll back the
payoffs from this sub-game,
the equilibrium payoffs from
this sub-game into the first
stage.
That's our method.
How are we going to do that?
Well we better first of all
figure out what those payoffs
are.
So what are the payoffs in this
equilibrium?
The payoffs in this mixed Nash
equilibrium are what?
Anyone see what the payoffs are
going to be if they're both
playing this mix?
Well presumably the payoff from
fight and the payoff from quit
must be the same,
is that right?
So we may as well choose the
easier one.
So I claim that the payoff from
quit is 0 x P + 0 x 1 - P which
is 0.
V / [V + C]
+ 0 .
C / [V + C]
but that's equal to what?
0, okay good.
So it's got to be the case
(kind of conveniently) that if
they do play this mixed strategy
equilibrium in stage 2,
the payoff they'll get from
playing it is 0.
That's going to make life a
little bit easier later on.
That's our new equilibrium in
the second sub-game.
Now let's roll that back to the
first game.
Here's our first game again,
and everything about this is
correct except what's down here.
So let's get rid of what's down
here.
Our analysis from before is
more or less still intact.
It's still the case,
that if they both quit they'll
get 0.
If they (Quit,
fight) they'll get (0,
V);
or (V, 0) and it's still the
case if they both fight they'll
both incur costs of C and
they'll both then get stage 2
continuation Nash payoffs.
Is that right?
But now instead of those
continuation Nash payoffs being
(V, 0) or (0,
V), those continuation Nash
payoffs are going to be what?
They're going to be 0.
So what we're going to do here
is we're going to backward
induct, or roll back,
those zero payoffs and come up
with the corresponding matrix to
describe the first stage of the
game.
Here it is.
Fight, Quit--I'll try to get it
right without Jake having to
correct me this time--little f,
little q.
This is A.
This is B.
And the payoffs here are (0,0)
here;
(0, V);
(V, 0) just as before;
and, in this box now,
we've got -C + 0 and -C + 0.
So it's exactly the same box we
saw before, but now the
continuation payoffs are just 0.
Again, what is this?
This is for the Nash
equilibrium--let's just say for
the mixed Nash equilibrium in
period 2.
Now what I want to do is I want
to find the mixed equilibrium in
period 1.
We found the mixed equilibrium
in period 2.
Now I want to find the mixed
equilibrium in period 1.
So what I could do here is I
could spend a lot of time.
I could put in a P and a 1 - P
and I could work out what mix of
Player B will make A
indifferent.
I could work out what mix of
Player A would make B
indifferent.
But has anybody noticed
something about this matrix?
What do you notice about this
matrix?
Somebody help me out?
Somebody's got to help me out
here.
Tell me something about this
matrix.
What's true about this matrix?
Student: It's the same
as the one above.
Professor Ben Polak:
It's the same as the one
above.
The matrix I just drew,
when I rolled back the payoffs
is exactly the same matrix that
I had here.
It's exactly the same matrix.
So we already know what the
mixed strategy equilibrium is in
this.
The mixed Nash equilibrium in
this matrix is both fight with
probability P = V / [V + C]
So now we're ready to show our
new sub-game perfect
equilibrium,
let's drag it down.
Here's our whole game,
we found the pure SPEs but now
we're ready to find the mixed
SPE.
The mixed sub-game perfect
equilibrium has Player A--before
I do that let me just give this
P a name.
Let me call this P, P*.
So V / [V + C],
let's call it P*.
So the mixed sub-game perfect
equilibrium has Player I mixing,
fighting with probability of P*
in the first stage;
and in the second stage,
again mixing,
fighting with probability of
P*.
So this is Player 1 and Player
2 does exactly the same thing.
While we're here,
what's the expected payoff for
each player if they're playing
this mixed sub-game perfect
equilibrium?
It's 0--the payoff from
this--the expected payoff is 0.
So now we're actually getting
somewhere, now we're really
getting somewhere.
So let's just take a deep
breath and see where we are.
We broke this game down,
this complicated game we played
in class, that conceivably--for
example,
when New York is playing New
Jersey--conceivably it could go
on all night.
Apparently not when the Texans
are playing each other or the
football team is playing the
baseball team,
but when we have New York and
New Jersey it could go on all
night.
We curtailed it to a two period
game, but in a minute,
we're going to go back to the
infinite game.
In this two period game,
I tried to argue--I'm trying to
convince you--that you could get
fighting occurring just in
equilibrium with absolutely
standard rational players:
nothing to do with pride,
nothing to do with reputation,
nothing to do with the fact
that these guys are crazy guys
who drunk the water in New York
and New Jersey,
God help them.
You can get fighting with
ordinary people in equilibrium.
What we've shown is the way in
which you can get fighting is in
a mixed strategy equilibrium.
In each period of the game,
people fight with probability
P.
That's just enough fight to
give the other side an incentive
to quit and just enough
probability of the other side
quitting to give the other side
an incentive to fight;
just exactly enough.
If they play that equilibrium
in every period,
there's some chance of the game
ending but with probability P,
the game goes forward to the
next period.
So you could potentially have
fights for two periods.
By the way, with what
probability would there be a
fight in both periods?
That's a good homework
question, I won't answer it
here, you can work it out at
home.
Should we do it here?
Anybody want to tell me?
So okay, with what probability
do we get a fight in the first
period;
a real fight,
a fight involving both players?
We need both players to fight,
each are fighting with
probability of P,
so the probability of both of
them fighting is what?
P².
So to get a fight in the first
period, the probability is
P².
To get a fight in both periods
is what then?
P^(4).
But we get a fight with
probability of P^(4) going
through.
We get fighting in equilibrium.
Moreover, we get some very
intuitive things that we already
learned in the Hawk-Dove game.
The probability of fight--so in
this equilibrium--the
probability of fights occurring
goes up as V goes up.
So the prize gets bigger,
you're more likely to see
fights occur:
that seems right.
It goes down in C.
So the probability of fights
occurring goes up in the size of
the prize--that seems
intuitively right--and down in
the cost of fighting.
Now, okay, that's reasonable,
but I claimed I could show you
this not in a two period game,
but in an infinite period game.
So let me spend the last five
minutes taking us to infinite
period games.
So everybody take a deep breath.
We're now going to consider
something, we've never done
before.
We're going to consider a game
that could go on forever.
It could go on forever.
The way we're going to do that
is to use the following idea,
the following picture.
So I can't really draw a true
tree for the infinite period
game.
The reason I can't draw a true
tree for the infinite period
game is: (1) I would run out of
chalk;
and (2) I'd run into lunch time.
But you can imagine what it
looks like.
It looks like this,
roughly speaking.
The infinite period game looks
something like this.
And then it goes again,
and then it goes again,
and so on, and it would go
right the way through the board
and work right the way across
whatever street that is,
right across campus.
That's what the infinite tree
would look like,
so I clearly can't really
analyze that object.
But what I want to show you is
that we can still solve this
game even though it's an
infinite period game.
How are we going to do that?
Let's look at a particular
stage.
Let's call the stage Stage
4,503 whatever that number was:
4,503, whatever it was.
So here is the stage,
this arbitrary stage,
and the tree for this arbitrary
stage looks like this.
What I'm going to do is:
this is Stage 4,503,
and what I'm going to add to
this is that before you get into
this stage,
you're going to incur sunk
costs.
If you go on playing after this
stage then you're going to get
continuation values.
So going into the beginning of
the game, you've incurred some
sunk costs and if you come out
on the other side and go on
playing,
you're going to play some
equilibrium and get continuation
values.
But otherwise everything else
is the same.
We still have (0,0) here,
we still have (0,
V) here, we still have (V,
0) here and here we still have
-C plus continuation values and
-C plus continuation values.
This is something we've seen
before.
This little box is something
we've seen before.
Essentially we've got sunk
costs in front,
but they're irrelevant.
We've got continuation values
at the end but we know how to
handle them, we just put them
into the payoffs.
So suppose now that in the
continuation game,
people play the mixed strategy
that we just found.
Suppose that in the
continuation game people mixed
with probability P:
so they fight with P* and quit
with probability 1 - P*.
Suppose in the continuation
game they're playing a mixed
strategy.
In that case,
what is the continuation value
of the game?
What is it?
It's 0 right.
If they're mixing in the
future, they always have the
option to quit so it must be
that the continuation value is
0.
So if they mix in the future
then the continuation value is
(0,0).
So now let's go back to this
board.
To make this board equivalent
to the board above,
all I need to do is one thing.
I need to add on some sunk
costs at the front.
I've got sunk costs at the
front.
I'm going to play the game.
And then I'm going to get,
instead of stage 2 values,
I'm going to get stage--what
was it?--4,503 and all stages in
the future values in here and
here, but otherwise it's the
same thing.
And what's convenient is:
all of those are 0 anyway.
Since they're all 0 anyway,
this matrix is still correct,
the continuation values are 0
and 0, these are now the
continuation values.
And so if I look for a
mixed-strategy equilibrium in
this game, it's something I've
solved already.
What's the mixed strategy
equiliibrium in this game?
Anybody?
It's exactly what we found
before.
Just as before,
I'm going to mix with
probability of V / [V + C].
Let's summarize,
we did something today--just
now--that we've never done
before.
We've looked at an infinite or
at least potentially infinite
period game: a game that could
go on forever.
The way in which we handled the
game that could go on forever
was what?
We noticed two things.
We noticed that part of the
game that comes before,
that part of the game that's
passed already,
anything that happened there is
just a sunk cost.
It's irrelevant.
It hurts if it's a cost.
It's nice if it's a gain.
But it's sunk,
you can't affect it now.
Anything in the future can be
summarized by the value,
the payoff I'm going to get in
the future by playing the
equilibrium in the future.
In this case,
the future meant mixing.
Mixing gave me the value of 0.
So here I am getting 0 from the
future.
Then I can just analyze the
game in the stage in which I'm
in, just as if it was an
ordinary, bog-standard,
simultaneous move game.
When we did so,
in this particular
example--we're going to see more
examples like this after the
break--but in this particular
example,
we found out something quite
surprising.
This thing we found out was,
in these war of attrition
settings, there is an
equilibrium with rational
players--more than that,
common knowledge of
rationality: everybody's
rational, everyone knows
everyone else is rational--there
are equilibria in which,
not only people fight but they
could fight forever.
In every period they fight with
some probability and we got an
extra prediction out of it,
a prediction that we weren't
expecting.
Let me just give you that
prediction, and then we'll leave
the class with that.
The extra prediction is this,
if we look at these wars of
attrition, and we keep track of
the time in which the--hang on
guys don't rush to the back
yet--one more thing.
If we look at the time in which
the games have gone on and keep
track of the probability that a
war will end at that time.
So imagine this is World War I.
You could imagine World War I
going for one year,
or two years,
or three years,
or 20 years or whatever.
The probability distribution in
this war of attrition is going
to look like this.
In every period,
the probability of continuing
is just P*².
So, in every period,
the chance that--as you get
further into the future there's
a greater chance the war will
end.
You can get very long,
very costly wars;
that's the bad news.
The good news is it doesn't
happen very often.
I guess we're all involved in a
rather large and costly war
right now, so I'll leave you
with that pleasant thought over
Thanksgiving.
Have a good break and we'll see
you afterwards.